(tense string music)
- [Soldier] We've tapped
into their radios.
We can confirm two divisions.
- [General] Confirmed.
We have an aerial visual.
- [Soldier] Copy?
- [General] Yes, yes, we
can hear them moving in.
- [Host] Only none of what the Germans
thought they could see or hear was real.
During World War II, a secret
division of the US Army,
now known as the Ghost
Army, conducted over 20
tactical operations, which resulted in
saving tens of thousands of lives.
The mission?
To trick the enemy into
thinking that their unit
of 1,000 men was actually
two divisions of 30,000 men.
But the Ghost Army wasn't made
up of traditional soldiers.
The majority were actors,
designers, advertisers,
and artists who had been
recruited from the top
art and design schools around the country.
And this army of artists
used their creativity
for an infantry of illusion.
Engineers developed inflatable tanks
which the artists would then paint.
These tanks could condense
down to fit into a portable bag
and inflate on demand,
much like a bouncy castle.
Audio engineers used large
speakers to play sound effects
of tanks and marching soldiers,
which had been pre-recorded at Fort Knox.
This marching army could
be heard from miles away.
Along with fake radio
messages sent into the signals
of the enemies, they
would also send actors
dressed as generals and
officers into local towns
to spread false information and rumors.
It wasn't until 1996, when
information about the Ghost Army
was declassified that
the world finally knew
about these masters of misdirection,
the unsung heroes of World War II.